in tekken sometimes the grand finals may
not be the best or the most hyped match
in a tournament
especially if the outcome is predictable
or pretty much one-sided bummer i mean
you know
it's tough anakin is so good but there
are some that really lived up to the
hype like an underdog win an impossible
comeback or toe-to-toe back and forth
action that is so close and competitive
that even one single mistake can change
the outcome of the whole match
as always my name is drew and these are
the top five best championship moments
in tekken tournaments
look at him he's not even back then he
was just holding back yeah
and like i said before he has a life
lead it's almost 15 seconds yeah he
knows you want to come in look at that
and there's the reset
squid punish on a jab i'm gonna wait for
something bigger look at that and match
point coming up here man chanel
oh my god that could have been a down
four too oh
oh boy
that it's not over yet is he gonna spin
that rage art
yes
oh
oh my god we're going to one more match
and saints like why aren't you dead why
can't i kill you
yeah look at satan hopefully he can keep
it together he looks like he's pitching
a deuce right now looks like he's having
a brain injury yeah make sure we have a
doctor ready amberland that is the best
oh wow the wind oh my god
first round china
there's the wall one
oh this is getting bad chanel needs to
make some moves right now he has way too
much life oh block
wow
look at the time it's not over
not even close
not even close to being over oh
it's safe hr
2016 king of office tournament champion
look at this pop off right now oh my god
that was amazing
holy moly but he's got rake he's got
rage he can still make this happen
oh
oh
oh oh
don't you want to go make it here i'm
pressing that and precious here you can
still get it
hey
and that should
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah we're going there two the wall's
right there too that's not enough to
have to kill and it's still alive but
the download is closed and me staying in
the round trying to go choose heroes
reset finals and he does it
wow
it's still 50 50. it will be low praise
[Applause]
[Applause]
all the way look at the damage
one hit the right down here
yeah he got it right
you're dead
[Applause]
we're going to a final final game
[Applause]
[Applause]
is
in the way he's to survive this combo
block john nixon hits the race drive
that might be it
it should be it yo john
game number one that's a lone pair
he has another opportunity this couple's
not gonna kill either fix up
the ranger with the pistol
john dick
that was madness he had no life left
right now looking for the reset
john ding resetting the grand final oh
but they're hitting now
oh
oh
this might be it this could be is he
taking the lead in the set he did yo
john dig up two to one
kudos a little bit of trouble he's got a
slippery
he's going to do a lot of damage back
too far away
on the back kudos is converted with the
electric into the wall here comes the
wall combo box another one oh getting
close it out
kudos closes it out of tithing up
johnny was down one round
oh the slow gun
this is gonna hurt big tv he might be oh
what the hell was that he put the brakes
on he had rage art available he didn't
go for it
but he got floated
this time all right kudos pulling it
back again that was scary for a moment
could have happened around early but he
closed it out to rage art anyway first
win yeah second we'll do that to you
right
the players in the grand finals reset
and john dick tied it up what's he going
to do with it one more hit away oh and
john dig again trying to win the
tournament can he do it here big block
big punish kunan is it gonna happen
we're going to a final final round
what's he going to do demon paw johnny
way behind he's got the ring he's got to
make a range come back down oh the red
guy's gonna dig
the walls right there the wall is right
there what's he gonna do fifty fifty
ceo 2018 here at daytona the crowd is
going wild i don't think i've ever seen
a spring kick win it like that a
defending victory for john did
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
yes
oh my god threatening the needle with
the electric hook fist
that was after a forward for a block
god i'm trying to move a little bit
and the low buried book is a machine
right now he's the machine right now
he's not dead but he does that for wait
a minute
and that's not enough and it goes to
pixel
[Music]
the pixel sweeps the leg flanks the
seats
get down for we got a reason
twitter timelines on how to get escape
situations
oh this is big he had sliver of life
left though that is a small pixel alike
how are you going to deal with it anakin
with the low
wait a minute wait a minute
here comes anakin
oh boys is the worst person to be
against jack oh
grand finals oh the second hit could
have been done so risky book was raised
now can you make a race come back
it's not over just yet but still can get
one laundry and end it
low praise got a pixel and anakin
oh my gosh yes sir
laser lancer follow-up here and again it
has some decent positioning though but
they trade blows how did trey
dash in with the hook fist he's crazy
man but he's got the first round and if
it was rage football great sorry i could
try to close it out
oh he followed him what's he going to do
oh the second is not landing
man times are wasting two count or four
four
he knew not to extend over extent and
they left him out of range now and he's
got rage to make this comeback
once again on tournament point and again
oh my goodness this might be nice
oh this is huge big opportunity for
anakin he's gonna get the wall
hey hey hey
daddy can try to close it out goes
through the middle oh here we go grand
grand finals final final game final
final round
and again
just outside of rage he has an
opportunity back in the open books gonna
have to be careful he does not want to
be back by the wall
oh
this is the one oh my gosh he's still
got good positioning though he's still
got great positioning
oh he's got rage
oh he trained
i win he got it he might win he's not
enough oh and again good
[Music]
thanks for watching be sure to subscribe
[Music]
you